what about
exercise your favorite topic
is there uh is there talking about it
yeah
okay great is there benefits to
longevity
uh from exercise well no doubt that's
that's proven
um just like fasting it's pretty clear
that that works
uh for example there are studies of
cyclists it was something like
people that cycle over 80 miles a week
have a 40
reduction in a variety of diseases
certainly heart disease
so that that's not even a question but
what's interesting is that we're
learning that
you don't need much to have a big
benefit it's an asymptotic curve
um and in fact if you overdo it you
probably have reduced benefits
particularly if you start to wear out
joints that kind of thing
but just 10 minutes on a treadmill a few
times a week getting your lose your
breath get hypoxia because it's cold
seems to be very beneficial for
long-term health
and that's the kind of exercise that i
like to do aerobic
though i do enjoy lifting weights so
that is what i call my exercise which
has other benefits including
maintaining hormone levels male hormone
levels
but also really why i do it is i want to
be able
to counteract the effects of sitting for
most of the day
yeah and as you get older you lose
muscle mass it's a percent or so a year
and i don't want to be frail when i'm
older and fall over and break my hip
which is
which happens every 20 seconds in this
country so maintaining that strength but
also doing the cardio for
the longevity for the avoiding the heart
disease
you